what do you want I'm just living life
man way that sounds like a line if I've
ever heard one
hi I'm John I'm a private investigator
here in Los Angeles and today I'm going
to attempt to deduce which of the six
available subjects were previously in a
romantic relationship together hi what's
your name Taylor Taylor and what's your
name dusty how long did you guys date
about two years what happened did I go
well you know how relationships go you
kind of like start strong and you enjoy
each other's company and then things
just kind of slow down and get
repetitive and kind of move your
separate ways ruthless that is cold
how'd you guys meet we met in Seattle
where she's from when'd you guys break
up April so you grew apart
I mean can you explain that a little bit
you just kind of have like different
interests like want different things out
of the future what do you want like
being single what do you want I'm a
little older than her so I'm looking to
like settle down and like have like a
long a long-term relationship how long
you work here about four months
how about you Taylor I started in
November all right Taylor I think I'm
done with you for the time being thank
you did you step down please what's your
name
Nadia Nadia she's single I am okay
calling him in single so what went wrong
just like fundamental differences it's
like things that we could not work
through like about what there's just
like a lot of trust issues boy this is a
real fun one huh how old was this
individual was when we mean like when we
met well are they alive 28 as far as you
know why don't you come sit over here
Destinee Thanks what's your name Blake
Blake what's that a tattoo of the robot
yeah Seattle are you from sale no from
Texas Oh a part a little town called for
sure in Houston
how long you been in LA ten months where
do you live I live in East Hollywood
yeah hauling yellow there nine months
you single now yeah oh wow okay kind of
fresh I don't mean yeah okay how long am
i single
we're eating up in Seattle no that was
just for vacation what you get for fun I
like hiking but um I'm also like a big
like homebody - what do you like to do
okay
why don't you come sit over here thanks
Nadia what's your name
Aleta yeah hold you I'm 25
mm-hmm where do you live what do you do
I'm a wedding once less what are you I'm
working on one for October and I had to
that's weekend two in the same weekend
oh yeah
what day what date that's wrong but okay
that's also wrong you get a roommate I'm
currently in a transitional period so
I'm back with my parents but before I
had a roommate on this one okay so who's
the roommate my ex okay so you you
bounced until something happens till he
he or she gets out right yeah
how long ago did that happen how many
why I'm like ready for that next phase
of my life they weren't maybe you and
Taylor should get together so what does
he want
I don't know you should ask I guess so
what do you want
when that sounds like a wine if I've
ever heard one to discover any and all
questions just live in life Blake thanks
why don't you come join me please what's
your name
Alex Alex yeah are you single yes
Braham where do you live I'm in Redondo
how long were you dating this person
almost three years what happened I guess
time just to be single because we both
really didn't have that much time after
our previous relationships before we
started dating
that's like a month for both of us hold
you 25 where'd you guys meet we work
together at a coffee shop in so you guys
met and then what did you come down here
together or how did that play out we
were just like best friends forever and
then like three years after we met we
just kind of hooked up you know how it
goes
or not I don't know so you're single
you're not really dating how long are
you not gonna be dating until you're
dating again
Oh are you dating ones last date you
went up I'm in a relationship where they
live
for how long I'm three months out and
it's exclusive yeah Nadia once you join
me again holdy who had the trust issues
with who did you have the trust issues
with them her did she have the trust
issues with you
she's she started all right I'm just
gonna talk through you know my thought
process here Aleta says she's been
single for three months
in fact you said both so you you bounced
until something happens till he he or
she gets out right yeah
how long did that happen how many three
on your second round of questioning you
said you've been in a relationship for
three months ones last date you went up
I'm in a relationship for how long
um three months down Nadiya evasive
vague trust issues Aleta was a little
defensive to tried to lie her way out of
a lie
looks pretty nervous right now as well
and everybody's lying
I do think you Lita is the key to my
downfall or triumph my first guess is
that you two used to date Alex will you
come sit over here my second guess is
that you guys used to date yeah I
thought you leader
I thought I sensed her getting kind of
uncomfortable as I drilled Alex more and
more but what threw me off is that near
the end oh I think it was when you said
I don't know got to lock it down or
something Alex got a huge kick out of
that and I in that bedroom I hold my
whole perception that there was some
sort of like you know heart heartbreak
or something like that going on here was
completely throw out the window so that
that threw me for a loop and I think you
know I Nadia is just so vasive and like
frankly kind of nervous no matter what I
thought maybe she was if so what went
wrong
just like fundamental differences it's
like things that we could not like about
what there's just like a lot of trust
issues but I want you know I wasn't
wrong I knew I think you weren't doing
bad but I spent a lot of time on you and
the more time I spent on you the more I
could feel and then you back then you
contradicted yourself which the
videotape will will confirm and then you
got a little combative Alita says she's
been single for three months
single for telling how I've been in a
relationship but in fact you said both
it sounds like this chick is definitely
hiding something
did I say chick I am pretty surprised
though
I thought out yeah cuz she was like Alex
you better not like laugh at everything
I say cuz I just what you did
yeah well I'll take it